[Music]
the first time I saw hundreds Hall was
July 1919 nothing that he prepared me
for the spell it cast when I saw the
house again thirty years later I could
hardly comprehend the change in the
place
[Music]
why don't you tell me what's going on
you wouldn't believe me mother this is
dr. Faraday how did you find the patient
little under the weather it's war shock
I brought Caroline home to nurse him
I've heard they're troubled very
cautious rushed about it a long time ago
who's the child here what are you doing
here
this isn't died before I was born
as something evil in this house that's
nonsense
[Music]
Betty what are you doing here
you're right four minutes but not all
Mrs S is upstairs trying itself today
but it's all noise
[Music]
that's impossible
your mind is playing tricks Susan is a
memory it can all be explained how
innocently bar
I'm worried doctor last night he said he
could smell smoke I couldn't smell
anything
these delusions seemed almost contagious
someone's playing games people are
capable of nasty impulses something in
this house that hates us
you do not belong here oh yes very
fictional weapon next there's a mystery
to me
you